الشباب احياء طهران يدعمونا تجمعا
احتجاجيا بدءا من اليوم
في مقر البسيج في بوشهر
عده انفجارات تدوي صباح اليوم في كيف
والجيش الاوكراني يسقط تسعه مسيرات في
اجواء العاصمه
في نهائي المونديال ميسي يحصد الكاس
ومكرون يجدد دعمه للمنتخب الفرنسي رغم
الهزيمه
يا شيخ
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره لاهم الانباء
من العربيه يقدمها لكم ابراهيم بدر اعلن
يا شباب احياء طهران دعمهم لتجمع
الاحتجاجيه بدءا من اليوم ولمده ثلاثه
ايام فيما حكم القضاء الايرانيه على سته
شبان بالسجن لمده تصل الى 22 عاما ياتي
هذا التواصل التظاهرات في العاصمه
الايرانيه كما اضرم محتجون النار في مقر
البسيج في مدينه بشار جنوبي ايران
[موسيقى]
الجنوبيه
سبونج بوب
الامريكي انه يجب على المجتمع الدولي ان
يمارس صلاحيته للرد على جرائم النظام
الايراني المستمره ضد شعبه واضافت اللجنه
عبر حسابها على تويتر بان العديد من
الايرانيين يواجهون خطر الاعدام مثل مجيد
رضا رحمه ورد الذي نفذت السلطات الايرانيه
لعقوبه في مؤخرا
ثلاث منظمه حقوق الانسان في ايران
النساجين يدعى محسن المنصوري قتل واصب 17
اخرون خلال اضطرابات شهيده سجن كرج على
بعد 30 كلم من طهران فقالت منظمه انا
الاضطرابات اندلعت عندما احتجت السجناء
على نقل معتقل الى الحبس الانفرادي قبل
اعدامه الوشيك واضافت بان السجناء في كراج
رددوا شعارات مناهضه للنظام منها الموت
للديكتاتور واسد الابواب وحطموا كاميرات
المراقبه
قالت وزاره الامن الايرانيه في بيان انها
اعتقلت اعضاء خليه يتجسسا زعمت انها تابعه
لجهاز الموساد الاسرائيلي واضافت بان
الخليه كانت تخطط لتنفيذ اعمال تخريبيه في
الصناعات الدفاعيه الايرانيه من خلال
انشاء شركات مزيفه وتسويق امني
صرحت الاداره العسكريه في اوكرانيا
اسقطت 9 طائرات مسيره ايرانيه الصنع في
ساعه مبكره من صباح اليوم في المجال الجوي
لكيف وقالت الاداره ان حاله تاخذ الجوي
مستمره في العاصمه الاوكرانيه لافته الى
ان القوه الروسيه تهاجم العاصمه بذخائر من
طراز شهد
يعتزلوا رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشه
سوناك الاعلان عن تزويد اوكرانيا بحزمه
جديده من الاسلحه خلال لقائه في لاتفيا
والذي يجمع قاده دول شمال اوروبا والبلطيق
اضافه الى هولندا وقال بيان صادر عن مكتب
سوناك بانا بريطانيا ستدعو قاده دول
التحالف الى الابقاء على مستويات الدعم
الحريري اوكرانيا او زيادتها عام 2023 كما
سيعلن هناك وبحسب البيان عن تزويدي بلادي
لاوكرانيا بمئه الالاف من قباء في مدفعيه
العمل المقبل بموجب عقد قيمته 250 مليون
جنيه استرليني
قال الرئيس الاوكرانيه للقوات الاوكرانيه
لازالت تسيطر على محمود في شرق اوكرانيا
رغم الهجمات الروسيه ولا فتاه زيلنسكي الى
ان حمايه الحدود هي اولويه وانكرانيا
جاهزه لجميع سيناريوهات الممكنه مع روسيا
وبيلاروسيا
ذكرت وكاله انترفاكس ان القوات الروسيه
المتواجده في بيلاروسيا ستجري تدريبات
ومنورات تكتيكيه دون ان تحدد الوكاله
الوقت المحدد لاجراء تلك المناوره وكانت
وزاره الدفاع بيلاروسيه قالت في وقت سابق
ان تسعه الاف جندي روسي تحركوا الى
بيروسيا من اجل حمايه حدودها
اعلن المتحدث باسم الكريم لاند متر بسكوف
ان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين سيتوجه
الى بيلاروسيا اليوم في زياره هي الاولى
في ثلاث سنوات وقال بسكوف ان الرئيس
الروسي سابحث مع نظيره البيلاروسي الكسندر
لوكيشنكو علاقات الشراكه الاستراتيجيه بين
البلدين ومستقبل دول الاتحاد وسيركزان
ايضا على القضايا الامنيه والاجراءات
المشتركه لمواجهه التحديات الراهنه
نفودته
كشفت مجله البريطانيه انك كبير
الدبلوماسيين الامريكيين هنري كيسنجر اكد
امكانيه وقف الحرب في اوكرانيا من خلال
الدبلوماسيه محدرا من ابعاد روسيا عن
ممارسه السياسه الاستراتيجيه وان الرغبه
في تفكيك موسكو قد تطلق العنانه لفوضى
نوويه عامه
روسيا مرتب ضد اوكرانيا تطالب اطراف دوليه
بوقف الحرب عبر تسويه دبلوماسيه شامله
احد كبار الدبلوماسيين الامريكيين اشار
وحسب مجله البريطانيه الى ضروره وقف
المواجهات والحد من نشوب حرب عالميه
الوقت يقترب للبناء على التغييرات
الاستراتيجيه التي تحققت ودمجها في هيكل
جديد لتحقيق السلام من خلال المفاوضات
كيسنجر كان اعلن عن اقتراحات ومسارات لم
تؤيدها اوكرانيا ودول غربيه
محذرا من ان الرغبه في تفكيك روسيا قد
تطلق العنان لفوضا نوويه عامه مشددا على
عدم ابعاد روسيا عن ممارسه السياسه
الاستراتيجيه لان الامر يمكن ان يحول
اراضيها التي تضم 11 منطقه زمنيه الى فراغ
متنازع عليه ومخاطر حقيقيه بسبب وجود الاف
الاسلحه النوويه باعتبارها واحده من اكبر
قوتين نوويتين في العالم
وبالتزامن قدم كيسنجر
لحلول ممكنه ربما تساهم في وقف الحرب
وجدتها كيف غير مناسبه وقف النار وانسحاب
اسيا الى الخطوط الاماميه ما قبل الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير بقاء ملف شبه جزيره
القرم محل مفاوضات اجراء استفتاء تحت
اشراف دولي للبث في امر الاراضي التي
ضمتها روسيا في 2014
في المقابل قال خبراء عسكريون وامنون ان
وقف حرب اوكرانيا يصطدم بعراقيل ابرزها
تجديد الاوكرانيين على خروج روسيا من
اراضيها كما دخلتها اول مره انسحاب الجنود
الروسي من اقليم دومباس ومناطق اخرى تمثل
5 مساحه اوكرانيا
فيما تعتبر موسكو انها حققت اهداف عمليتها
الخاصه بضم اقليم دون باس الى الاتحاد
الروسي وسط تسريبات عن امكانيه تخلي روسيا
عن مناطق مثل خرسون وزابولوجيا كما فعلت
بسحب جنودها من كاركيف
هو حسب تقارير امنيه فان روسيا تواصل
توسيع نفوذها من شبه جزيره القرم الى
ضواحي روستو جنوبا فيما تحسن اوكرانيا
ترسانتها العسكريه باسلحه اوروبيه
وامريكيه لاخراج القوات الروسيه من
اراضيها جاسم محسن العربيه
قال الرئيس وزراء الحكم الليبيه فتحي بشره
ان بلاده لن ترضى بتسليم المواطن ليبي ابو
عجيبه مسعود المريمي الى الولايات المتحده
في اطار قضيه تفجير طائره لوكربيه واضاف
باشا
من ان البلاد تمر الان بمرحله حساسه
وخطيره وحمل المجلس الاعلى للدوله حكومه
البيبه المسؤوليه القانونيه والاخلاقيه
بعد تسليم الريمي الى واشنطن
نشاطنا مستمره وتتابعونا فيها بعض الفاصل
ماسك ينتظرون نتيجه استطلاع عن الراي
لاتخاد قرار بشان اداره تويتر
مفيد العربيه الى الدوحه ليث بن زارينا
جانبا من احتفالات المنتخب الارجنتيني بعد
تتويجه وخروجه موكبه الى شوارع الدوحه
نعم نحن هنا في درب السيل كما تشاهدون
هناك موكب موكب المنتخب الارجنتيني الذي
فاز بكاس العالم هنا في قطر بقياده ميسي
طبعا
نشاهد في الصوره الموكب الذي يقل
اللاعبون
وهم على متن هذه الحافله ااه في الصوره
واذا شاهدنا الان مباشره بعد الخيول وبشكل
الحصيد العربيه
المنتخب الارجنتيني وهم على متن هذه
الحافله يقومون باجراء التحيه والقاء
التحيه على على المشجعين الذين نشاهد هنا
هذا هو ال- ال- هذا هو المنتخب الارجنتيني
على متن هذه الحافله يقومون همم بالقاء
التحيه على جميع همم
المشجعين والذين يهتفون ميسي واسماء اخرى
من لاعبي المنتخب ويقولون راموس ارخنتينا
لحظات تاريخيه لحظات تاريخيه ونشاهد ايضا
خلف حافله اللاعبين نشاهد الحافله الرسميه
التي تنقل اللاعبين بعد ذلك عندما ينتهوا
من عبر درب الوسيل او من عبور ضرب الوزير
همم من عبور ضرب الوسيل من عبور ضرب
الوسيل متجهين على متن حافلاتهم الى مكان
اقامتهم التي طبعا هناك ستقام احتفالات
خاصه لهم والجماهير بانتظارهم امام هذا
الفندق او مكان الاقامه ومن ثم ستنتهي
الاحتفالات في ساعات الصباح الباكر ليث
بازاري العربيه الدوحه قطر
[تصفيق]
عبر الرئيس الفرنسيه فخري بما حققه منتخب
بلاده في نهائيات كاس العالم على الرغم من
الخساره القاسيه التي مني بها في النهائي
امام الارجنتين بركلات الترجيح وقلم مكروم
في تغريده عبر حسابه الرسميه على موقع
تويتر ان المنتخب الفرنسي جاء علنا نحلم
مصحوبا بمقطع فيديو يكشف فيه تفاصيل لقائه
باللاعبين في غرفه تبديل الملابس عقبا
انتهاء المباراه
جميل
وصف المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه نت برايس الانتخابات البرلمانيه
في تونس بالخطوه الاولى الاساسيه نحو
استعاده المسار الديمقراطي في البلاد
مؤكدا في الوقت ذاته ان ضعف نسبه المشاركه
بالتصويت يظهر الحاجه الى مزيدا من
المشاركه السياسيه على نطاق اوسع خلال
الاشهر المقبله
اجى الملياردير الامريكي الى الماسك
متابعين بعد ما اطلق استطلاع عن الرئيس
حول تنحيه من منصبه كرئيس لمنصه تويتر
وسال ماسك متابعين في تغريده على تويتر
اذا كان يجب ان يتنحى عن منصبه كرئيس
لمنصه التويتر مؤكدا الالتزامه بنتائج هذا
الاستطلاع
في خبر اخر يتعلق بشركه تويتر قالت الشركه
انها ستحذف الحسابات المنشاه حصريا لغرض
الترويجي لمن عصاه التواصل الاجتماعي
الاخرى وكذلك المحتوى الذي يتضمن روابط او
اسماء مستخدمين واضافت ان من شان التحرك
ان يؤثر على محتوى المنصات مثل الفيسبوك
وانستغرام
المملوكتين لشركه ميتا الى جانب مسدوده
سوشيال توتال وغيرها بينما سيسمح بمشاركه
المحتوى ما بين المنصه
اطلقت كوريا الشماليه صاروخين بالسين
باتجاه بحر الشرق بعد يومين من اعلان
اختبارات
جديده وقالت هيئه الاركان للجيوش الكوريه
الجنوبيه انها رصدت صاروخان
متوسطي المدى
الشماليه في شمال غرب البلاد
[موسيقى]
دخلت مفاوضات الامم المتحده الحاسمه
لابرام اتفاقيه سلام من اجل الطبيعه
مرحلتها نهائيه بمشاركه وزراء البيئه من
جميع انحاء العالم المجتمعين في مونتريال
الكنديه ويسعى الوزراء الى ابرام اتفاقيه
تاريخيه بشان التنوع البيولوجي على غرار
اتفاقيه باريس لمناخ في 2015
[موسيقى]
توقفت حركه المرور في العاصمه الروسيه
موسكو وارغيت الرحلات الجويه وذلك بسبب
تساقط الثلوج الغير
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
فيني عندنا شهاده تفكيرهم بابرز عناوين
شباب واحيائي طهران يدعمون تجمع احتجاجيا
بدءا من اليوم واضراب ناري في مقر البسيج
في بوشهر
عده انفجارات تدوي صباح اليوم والجيش
الاوكراني يسقط تسعه مسيرات في اجواء
العاصمه
وفي نهائي المونديال ميسي يحصد الكاس
ومكرونه يجدد دعمه للمنتخب الفرنسي رغم
الهزيمه
[موسيقى]